¡Bienvenidos a África! O más bien debería decir, bienvenidos a casa.
Porque aquí es donde en realidad empezó todo, ¿no es así?
Examinando fósiles datados de hace varios millones de años
todo apunta a la evidencia de que la vida
para la especie humana, tal como la conocemos, empezó aquí mismo.
Estaremos participando de un increíble viaje los próximos cuatro días.
Vais a oír historias de África: El Próximo Capítulo.
Cuentos fantásticos, anécdotas de los oradores.
Pero yo quiero darle la vuelta a eso por un momento,
poner las cartas sobre la mesa y aclarar las cosas, por decirlo de algún modo.
¿Qué es lo peor que habéis oído sobre África?
Y ésta no es, en realidad, una pregunta retórica.
En realidad quiero que me respondáis.
¡Vamos! Lo peor.
Hambre.
Corrupción.
Más.
Genocidio.
SIDA.
Esclavitud.
Es suficiente.
Todos nosotros hemos oído esas cosas.
Pero esto es sobre África, sobre la historia que no hemos oído.
Las historias que queremos saber,
y las historias que existen sobre relatos positivos.
Una parte de mi charla va a tratar sobre las oportunidades de inversión
que existen en este continente.
Para separar el retórico de la realidad, el hecho de la ficción,
para ir hasta los datos actuales y las estadísticas que existen
sobre los hechos que están ocurriendo actualmente sobre el terreno
que hacen de África una oportunidad y una opción de inversión real para ti.
Así que sigamos porque África
está, hasta cierto punto, cambiando de dirección.
Un cambio de dirección en términos de cómo maneja su imagen,
y de cómo toma control de su propio destino.
Y los cambios de dirección son una parte integrante
del tema en el que me he centrado durante la mayor parte de mi carrera profesional.
Todo empezó hace casi una década,
como un joven consultor en McKinsey & Company
en su primera oficina africana en Johanesburgo.
Allí trabajábamos con destacados presidentes ejecutivos
de cuestiones relacionadas con África y con compañías africanas en proceso de cambio,
convirtiendo las compañías no sólo en lo mejor en África
sino también los mejores globalmente.
Pero en realidad, formalicé mi atención en estos cambios de dirección
cuando estaba completando mi MBA en los Estados Unidos.
Todo empezó con una fantástica llamada.
Era de Rosabeth Moss Kanter,
gurú de la Harvard Business School y profesora mía.
Y ella me dijo, "Quiero escribir un caso, Euvin --
un caso sobre un líder en el sector público
que tenga lecciones que dar al mundo empresarial.
Y el líder que vino a mi mente fue Nelson Mandela
Porque Nelson Mandela, cuando tomó el poder
como el primer presidente electo democráticamente de Sudáfrica,
afrontó la situación de un país
que pudo haberse deslizado hasta el abismo del caos.
Pero él empezó el país por el camino de un ciclo positivo.
Ahora el caso, "Nelson Mandela: el Líder del Cambio"
se convirtió en parte de la base de una investigación para un capítulo
del nuevo libro de Rosabeth, titulado "Confianza"
Y "Confianza" se convirtió en un bestseller del New York Times
y llegó al número uno en la lista de bestsellers de libros de tapa dura de la Business Week.
El motivo de que os cuente esta historia es porque, más tarde, cuando fui entrevistado
en SABC África, en un programa panafricano, me preguntaron,
"¿Cuál es la lección clave, o aquello de lo que disfrutaste más?" --
y es que era un gran privilegio ser parte de ese proyecto.
La lección que obtuve de eso fue que era África, una historia africana,
la que se había utilizado para compartir con el resto del mundo
sobre la importancia de los puntos de referencia para los cambios empresariales.
¡África estaba siendo usada como ejemplo de una historia exitosa!
Por eso quiero compartir con vosotros una historia personal
sobre un cambio o una transformación.
Y eso tiene que ver conmigo.
Porque en 1994, empaqué algunas cosas en una mochila
y me fui un año de viaje
en mitad de mi carrera universitaria.
¡Deberíais haber visto la reacción de mis padres!
(Risas)
Pero muy pronto, me encontré desde la parte sudeste de África --
en Sudáfrica - hasta el norte, en Egipto.
Busqué los lugares más remotos.
Fui al oasis Siwa - esa fue una de mis paradas.
Y el oasis Siwa es famoso por bastantes cosas,
pero lo importante es que fue el sitio
donde Alejandro Magno fue
cuando quiso encontrar lo que el destino tenía preparado para él.
La leyenda dice que Alejandro caminó por el desierto.
La mitad de su batallón fue aniquilado en una tormenta de arena.
Y el mito cuenta que tuvo una audiencia con el oráculo,
y que éste le predijo su destino de grandeza.
Esto ocurrió en el 300 a. C.
Así que África ha sido vista, desde hace mucho tiempo, como un lugar para ir en busca de respsuestas
Bien, lo que recuerdo sobre Siwa
fue la mágica vista del cielo por la noche.
Sin ningún tipo del fuente lumínica natural, Siwa es uno de esos increíbles lugares
en los que al mirar hacia arriba ves un tapiz perfecto.
Un rápido avance al 2002.
Estoy sentado en Cambridge, Massachussets,
en la Conferencia para el Desarrollo de la Asistencia Sanitaria.
Y veo la misma imagen, pero desde el bando opuesto.
Una imagen satelital mirando hacia abajo, hacia la Tierra.
Y fue esa imagen la que creó tal impacto en mí
porque nunca lo olvidaré. Recuerdo el momento exacto.
Quería compartir con vosotros la imagen de lo que vi en ese momento.
La primera cosa que vi fue Norteamérica de noche --
brillante, en toda su gloria. Una sensación cálida. Luz.
Y luego lo vi -- África. Casi literalmente el "Continente Oscuro."
Y mientras África pudiera ser oscura,
aquello que me reveló el mensaje
fue que éste es el desafío al que nos estamos enfrentando,
pero es también una oportunidad.
Porque mientras África puede ser oscura -- aparte de los pocos puntos de luz
que existen en el norte, en el sur y en otras áreas --
Está al rojo vivo con la luz de los corazones
de los millones de personas que hay allí.
Emprendedores, gente dinámica, gente con esperanza.
Fue George Kimble, el geógrafo, quien dijo
que, "Lo único oscuro sobre África es nuestra ignorancia sobre ella."
Así que empecemos arrojando luz sobre este increíble y ecléctico continente
que tiene tanto que ofrecernos.
Empecemos desempacándolo.
África es el segundo continente más grande, una masa de tierra, segunda después de Asia.
Es también el segundo continente más poblado,
con 900 millones de personas.
En realidad -- volviendo a la masa de tierra - África es tan grande
que podrías meter dentro los Estados Unidos,
China y Europa entera dentro de África, y aún así tener espacio de sobra.
África es el hogar de 1.000 lenguas --
2.000 es otra de las estimaciones de las que se habla --
con más de 2.000 lenguas y dialectos.
Pero podríais decir, "Invierte en África usando más de 1.000 lenguas,
y no encontrarás mucha diferencia."
¿Qué nos dicen los datos?
Como banquero inversor, estoy inmerso en el flujo cruzado de la información
y de los cambios que están teniendo lugar en los mercados capitales.
Así que quiero compartir con vosotros algunos de estas señales de liderazgo, o indicios
y los aires de cambio que están soplando en este continente.
Así que empecemos con eso.
Empecemos a un nivel alto, por los macro factores.
La inflación, en general, está bajando en África --
ese ese el primer signo --
en muchos países que están alcanzando cifras de dos dígitos.
Así que empecemos observando algunos de ellos.
Yo lo llamo mi grupo Z.E.N.
Zambia: del 2004 al 2006, va desde el 18 por ciento de inflación
hasta el nueve por ciento.
Egipto: del 16 por ciento hasta el 8.4 por ciento.
Nigeria, una situación semejante:
del 16 por ciento hasta el ocho por ciento. Dígitos únicos.
Más fascinante aún, encontramos otros países -- Sudáfrica,
Mauritania, Namíbia -- todos en cifras de un sólo dígito.
Pero ésa es solo parte de la historia. Encontramos tendencias similares con las monedas --
monedas que están llegando a un momento extremo de estabilidad.
Pero eso es observando la imagen general.
Por eso, el primer mito que hay que disipar es que África no es un país.
sino que está formada por --
(Aplausos)
Está formada por 53 países distintos.
Así que la misma definición -- decir "invierte en África" -- es inútil.
No tiene sentido.
Cada país tiene una propuesta de valores única.
Puedes ganar dinero, puedes perder dinero en África.
Pero las oportunidades, muchacho, existen.
Y esto es de lo que va hoy --
de la discusión de esas mismas oportunidades.
Así que empecemos introduciéndonos en los países
y en el material y los datos específicos.
He sido elegido recientemente, tal como Emeka ha mencionado,
como el Presidente de la Cámara de Comercio sudafricana en América.
Estoy muy orgulloso y feliz de representar ese papel
porque es una posición fascinante en la que estar.
Poder escuchar este diálogo que está justo empezando a aumentar en importancia y velocidad,
sobre las decisiones de mercado y las compañías que quieren venir.
Así que la primera escala es: hablemos un poco sobre Sudáfrica.
Pero no la Sudáfrica de la que siempre hablamos --
el oro, los minerales, la infraestructura del Primer Mundo --
sino un poco sobre el otro lado de todo eso.
Por ejemplo: Sudáfrica fue votada recientemente como la primera destinación
para las primeras 1.000 empresas británicas con centrales de llamadas externas.
La misma lengua, zona horaria, etcétera. Tiene sentido.
Algunos otros titulares que han llegado recientemente a Sudáfrica
fueron Bain Capital y KKR, los peces grandes del capital privado.
Titular en Sudáfrica: "Han aterrizado." Bastante siniestro.
Pero, ¿para qué estaban allí? Para adquirir activos.
La adquisición de Edcon por parte de Bing's Capital, un gran minorista, es un testimonio
de la confianza que están empezando a depositar en la economía.
En realidad es un juego a largo plazo.
Ser un minorista, es una apuesta en la creencia
de que esta clase media que está creciendo continuará creciendo,
de que este boom y esta confianza en el gasto del consumidor continuará.
De todas formas, la historia de África, y mi centro de atención, va más allá de Sudáfrica
porque muchas cosas están ocurriendo.
Sin duda alguna, Nigeria está claramente en la zona potencial.
Desafíos - y vamos a oír hablar mucho de Nigeria en estos cuatro días.
Pero mirando el trabajo de Goldman Sachs - tuvimos el famoso informe BRIC.
El nuevo informe, "El Próximo Once", subraya que hacia el 2020
Nigeria va a estar entre las 10 primeras economías del planeta.
Es una oportunidad para invertir. Pensad en ello.
¿Hay alguien - nuestros bancos, nuestros inversores --
que esté pensando seriamente en ir a Nigeria?
Si no lo has pensado, ¿por qué no?
¿Qué está ocurriendo en Nigeria? Un par de cosas.
Me gustaría hablar sobre ello desde la perspectiva del mercado de capitales.
Señales de liderazgo de nuevo.
El Guarantee Trust Bank ha emitido el primer Euro Bono
fuera de África, y esto excluye Sudáfrica.
Pero el primer Euro Bono, el aumento del capital internacional
exterior, fuera de su propio balance general,
sin ningún tipo de apoyo externo --
es una indicación de la confianza que se está dando en la economía.
Sin ningún tipo de apoyo externo
una compañía nigeriana aumentando el capital externo.
Es un signo de aquello que está por venir.
Echando un vistazo a la industria del petróleo, África provee el 18 por ciento
del suministro de petróleo de los EE.UU. El Oriente Medio un 16 por ciento.
Es un compañero estratégico importante.
Pongamos Nigeria en perspectiva.
De 2.2 a 2.4 millones de barriles de petróleo por día.
La misma liga que Kuwait. La misma liga que Venezuela.
Pero con África, tenemos que tener cuidado con esto.
Y Emeka y yo hemos tenido este tipo de discusiones.
Tenemos que alejarnos de aquello llamado "la maldición de la materia prima"
Porque no se trata del petróleo, no se trata de la materia prima.
Para que África sea realmente sostenible,
tenemos que ir más allá, hacia otras industrias.
Así que analicemos esto de forma rápida,
y voy a pasar a través de esto muy, muy, muy rápido,
porque puedo ver ese reloj en la cuenta atrás.
¿Qué más está ocurriendo allí? Egipto.
Egipto está fundando la primera gran zona industrial --
2.8 mil milliones de inversión.
Conocí el anuncio justo hace algunas semanas.
Al lado del Mediterráneo, cerca de Alejandria --
textiles, petroquímicas.
Está siendo administrado por una compañía de inversiones ubicada en Singapur.
Así que quieren emerger como una industria energética
a través de las industrias -- alejadas del petróleo.
Echemos un vistazo a la agricultura. Veamos la silvicultura.
¿Qué está ocurriendo allí?
La semana pasada en Tanzania, tuvimos el lanzamiento
de la East African Organic Produce Standard.
De nuevo, reunidos granjeros y reunidos juntos tenedores de apuestas
en África Oriental para fijar estándares para los productos orgánicos. Mejores precios.
Eso se relaciona con granjeros a pequeña escala
en términos de no pesticidas, no fertilizantes.
Otra vez, una oportunidad para afrontar los mercados y conseguir un mejor precio.
Uganda: la New Forest Company,
replantando y renovando sus bosques. ¿Por qué es esto tan importante?
A medida que las necesidades energéticas se enfrentan y la electricidad se hace necesaria, vamos a necesitar
postes para extender la electricidad.
Pero aquí está lo irresistible de la oferta.
Van a aprovecharlo con beneficios a base de carbón.
Volvamos a Nigeria.
El sector bancario ha sufrido una tremenda transformación,
de más de 80 bancos hasta 25 bancos. Fortalecimiento del sistema.
¿Pero qué está pasando allí? Sólo el 10 por ciento del país tiene depósitos en los bancos.
La población más numerosa de África está en Nigeria.
Más de 135 millones de personas. Pensad en ello.
Hay sólo 700 cajeros automáticos en el país. Oportunidad.
Lo mismo para las telecomunicaciones a lo largo del país.
Ahora echemos un vistazo al continente como una unidad.
La gente observa las carreteras, por ejemplo, y dicen,
"Angola: el 90 por ciento de las carreteras están sin asfaltar. ¡Ah, problema!"
Es más caro transportar productos. Los precios de los productos suben,
la inflación se ve afectada.
Nigeria: el 70 por ciento de las carreteras está sin asfaltar. Zambia: el 80 por ciento.
En general, más del 50 por ciento de las carreteras está sin asfaltar.
¡Esto es una oportunidad! Necesidades energéticas -- es una oportunidad.
Así que, ¿cuáles son las señales que nos indican que las cosas están cambiando?
Veamos los mercados de valores en África.
Si yo tuviera que preguntarte, "¿Cuál ha sido, en el 2005, el mercado de valores
o la bolsa de valores más productiva en el mundo? ¿Vendría Egipto a tu mente?
En el 2005, el mercado de valores egipcio -- la bolsa de valores -- devolvió más del 145 por ciento.
¿Qué está ocurriendo en algunos de los demás países?
Veamos algunas cifras del 2006. Kenya: más del 60 por ciento. Nigeria: más del 40 por ciento.
Sudáfrica: en los 20 por ciento. Tantos por ciento elevados.
Estas son tendencias que están teniendo lugar.
Pero en cualquier decisión de inversión, la cuestión clave es,
"¿Cuál es mi inversión alternativa?"
Porque hoy en día en África, estamos compitiendo globalmente por el capital.
Y el capital global es agnóstico -- no profesa lealtades.
Hay un sobreendeudamiento en los EE.UU, y la clave es la ganancia del rendimiento.
Lo que África está proporcionando es un juego de diversificación,
además de oportunidades de ganancias en el rendimiento para el inversor
que es consciente de lo que él o ella está haciendo
Ahora bien, cuando miramos a África respecto a otras cosas,
y países en África respecto a otras cosas,
las comparaciones se convierten en importantes.
Diez años atrás, había muy pocos países
que recibieron tasas de soberanía del
Standard & Poors, Moody's y Fitch's.
Hoy, dieciséis países africanos, y creciendo,
tienen tasas soberanas del país. ¿Qué significa esto?
Tomemos Nigeria de nuevo: doble B negativa --
en la liga de Ucrania y Turquía. Inmediatamente tenemos una comparación.
La columna vertebral de la toma de decisiones en cuanto a inversiones
para los poseedores globales de capital.
Algunas otras cifras. Sudáfrica: triple B positiva. Botswana: A positiva.
Burkina Faso: B negativa. Etcétera.
De hecho, uno de los grandes organismos está estableciendo una oficina en África.
¿Por qué están haciendo eso? Porque esperan que las inversiones les sigan.
Así que uno de los mayores signos de liderazgo,
y una de los puntos finales que quiero mencionar es
algo interesante que leí: que la CNBC
había fundado su primer canal de televisión africano. ¿Por qué está haciendo esto la CNBC?
Es el canal 24 horas de notícias africano.
Lo están haciendo porque esperan que ocurran cosas.
Yo y tú, las inversiones que vamos a hacer,
las inversiones que el mundo va a hacer --
eso es el canal 24 horas de noticias dedicado a África.
Así que ése es el cambio que está por venir.
En conclusión, me gustaría volver a la imagen exacta
que hizo tal impacto en mí durante todos esos años atrás.
Y esta vez voy a daros la imagen completa de lo que vi en el 2002,
y pediros que cuando penseis en cuál puede ser vuestro papel en África,
penseis en vuestro viaje en términos de traer luz a este continente.
Porque hay disponibles oportunidades increíbles.
Y pensad sobre el concepto de transformación
en lo profundo de vuestra mente,
porque las cosas pueden dar un giro bastante rápido.
En 1899, Joseph Conrad publicó "El Corazón de la Oscuridad",
un cuento de horror a lo largo del río Congo.
Si uno mira atentamente, en el río Congo
hay una de esas luces brillantes. Y ese es el verdadero río Congo
generando luz -- el viejo corazón de la oscuridad --
ahora generando luz con energía hidroeléctrica.
Esa es una transformación del poder de las ideas.
Así que el próximo paso, en estos próximos cuatro días,
es explorar más de estas ideas.
Y acaso, si puedes, mantén siempre esta imagen en tu mente.
Porque cuando a lo mejor nos reunamos en un futuro lejano, en el 2020,
esa imagen será muy diferente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)